hello how are we doing
feeling good after lunch
Perfect all right so let's go ahead and
get started the next few moments
thank you so I'm sure a few of you have
already heard a few times a day so I'm
sorry that I'm repeating it it's getting
annoying at this point but I am Brianna
Williams and I'm a lecturer in the
comparative media studies and writing
Department here at MIT this afternoon I
will be introducing Dr Kelly Moore
associate professor of media culture and
communication at NYU and the author of
the newly released work legal
spectatorship slavery and the visual
culture of domestic violence which I
highly recommend by the way a bearing
witness Seeking Justice we hope to
incorporate creative forms of media
namely visual media in our development
of new Frameworks for social justice and
Dr Moore's work she furthers our
understanding of how the image of
domestic violence has altered and can
continue to alter legal and extra legal
spaces she does so by examining how
witness testimony and witness flesh is
translated and transformed once absorbed
into legal processes and the political
knowledge surrounding domestic violence
she uncovers historical and ongoing
efforts by state powers to subjugate the
presentation of both crime and the
victims without full regard for their
autonomy or consent ultimately
compromising their agency as they seek
Justice it's not difficult to expand our
interpretation of the domestic sphere
and project its implications beyond the
private household in our national home
the United States and Beyond its borders
State sanctioned violence occurs daily
and it's the images of these abuse their
uses interpretations their
transmutations that have often
maintained the recurrence of a violent
history but now offer us the tools with
which we can redefine that history if
only we hold fast to our agency as Dr
Moore posits through mediation
authentication and solidarity
since earning our PhD at UC San Diego
completing her post-doctoral fellowship
at UC Berkeley and Publishing
extensively Dr Morris found a new home
for her vital research at the center for
the Humanities she continues exploring
the potential of a method used in her
past work courtroom watching to further
expose media history its use of trauma
narratives and the popularization of
certain forms of evidence some real and
others falsified
no doubt understanding the pre-existing
Frameworks that Define courtroom
Aesthetics will allow us further agency
in forming our own in the pursuit of
Justice namely legal justice which is
why I'm so excited today to be
introducing Dr Kelly Moore in her
presentation moving images in absentia
courtroom looking in the age of hyper
mediation welcome Kelly
[Applause]
oh
yeah
okay
let's make sure
yes oh hi
um
thank you very very much Brianna for
that very kind introduction
um
and I want to express my tremendous
gratitude to Professor Kenneth Manning
for hosting this event and inviting me
to it a very generous very generous
um invitation as well as Samantha
Fletcher who helped with a number of
linked logistical issues and everyone
else who whose hands and labor touched
this conference in any way thank you so
much it's been really wonderful to be
here
um
and I would like
to also think the fellow Scholars here
who's critical in steadfast efforts
toward the question of visual culture
and criminal justice are shifting our
ability to understand what so many
repressed and silenced communities have
already known and experienced of the
mediation of Criminal Justice and its
origins in the anglo-american legal
context
um
so I am a scholar whose work brings
together law media
black studies and I'm interested in how
we come to the truth the milias through
which we come to the truth
the architectures that we use the spaces
that we inhabit to come to legal
decisions I'm interested in questions of
what makes something testimonial and
that's what I'll talk about today using
some materials from from my book and
then if there's time and that's actually
maybe the better argument if there's
time I'll talk about a project that
comes out of of my first monograph
this Symposium has brought together a
number of leading Scholars conducting
some of our deepest inquiries into the
identity and origins of photographic
evidence the effective dimension of
photographic evidence videography and
its influence on expressive and
narrative legal cultures the work has
expanded the analytical lens of video by
emphasizing the Sonic elements of
videography making ways of hearing the
of hearing the image co-eval with ways
of seeing the image importantly these
timely projects here at the conference
do not take for granted the presumption
of the availability of the audience as
structuring of the history of witnessing
and its political importance
the need for evidentiary photography and
moving images assumes an audience to
view it post it like it tweet it comment
follow curate
this is where I'll try to focus a few
interventions and provocations
this afternoon my remarks are concerned
with the interaction of Law and visual
culture in the era of ubiquitous social
media
and I will submit
that were our political moment where we
depend less and less on formerly trained
media professionals I.E traditional
journalists for documentation of State
oppression in a time of Greater
awareness of cultures and Amnesia where
the routines of police work are ever
more scrutinized by techno savvy public
we need to return to those spaces where
the live production of recording is
forbidden
absented erased confiscated left
unthought under theorized to comprehend
the limits of public witnessing in order
to strategize where to push further to
access a more thoughtful critique more
transformed Justice more life
I'll put the provocation up first
is it possible that the democratization
and decentralization of the of social
media technology we use to proliferate
our witnessing participates in the
centralization of State Control through
courtroom power
second how do we put into conversation
the fact that the U.S public that in the
U.S public witnessing is on the increase
in the same political moment courtroom
trials are on the decline and I'll talk
more about that
legal scholar Jocelyn Simonson draws our
attention to our current post-trial
world in which 95 percent of criminal
convictions result from plea Bargains
meaning that juries have fewer roles and
responsibilities to represent the public
in courtroom trials
today bearing witness is mediated by
Twitter Instagram Facebook and Tick Tock
and ways that should make us curious for
the whereabouts of juries but also and
more importantly wonder about the status
of the courtroom and its audience which
is to say that bearing witness should
also happen in the courtroom more
this talk is about the space and social
dynamics of courtrooms where photography
and videography are interdicted
as such my talk today focuses on the
control over recording Visual Evidence
in the courtroom milieu and by courtroom
milieu I mean the historical
communication Pathways between law
enforcements
um criminal investigation and the
players in the courtroom judges police
attorneys Court officers juries and the
audience
I suggest that the absence of
Photography and videography has a binary
and closed circuit relation to the
proliferation of Photography and
videography which demand our attention
the proliferation of Citizen photography
and videography an analysis must be
understood as a system of cybernetic
control which I'll explain a little bit
later
in the spirit of a feminist killjoy I'll
offer some cautionary points and
clarifications concerning the social
media transformation of public
witnessing and its interdisciplinary
study
these points and clarifications will
draw from examples from my own study of
the ascendance of Visual Evidence in
domestic violence in the U.S courtroom
and public culture I'll then turn to how
this study expanded into a founding of a
court watch at my University
so
um I came to this project through
looking at or coming across images of
battered women
in a life a few couple of lifetimes ago
when I was working in a courthouse as a
researcher in in New York and I'm going
to show a couple of those images and
this is sort of I guess it's my my
trigger warning which I completely
deconstructed with students the images a
few of them are authentic but the
majority of them are our art and
performance pieces
um
these are cosmetically simulated
domestic violence images this is a an
actress whose name I forget and a model
these are images used to advertise
public awareness of domestic violence
um this one here for the Baltimore
Ravens and the Super Bowl and the up to
the uptick in domestic violence
during the Super Bowl and this is
another just an interview with an
actress I believe for People magazine
where they staged her in this way
because reasons
um these are faked images images like
these began for me a Macabre
connoisseurship of some really unsavory
digital files and this is the conference
for that because I think of London all
of the scholars here have this
collection of of really unsavory
material
um and one of the affordances of social
media is its flexibility and modifying
filtering deconstructing and simulating
the truth
while trick photography has been around
since the Inception of the medium and
rituals of Cosmetics even longer the
ubiquity of social media particularly
digital photography has brought ever
more opportunities to fake it
Faking It In this case in this case the
wounds of domestic abuse using social
media has also made its way into law
when I allowed myself to be led by
representational Motif and genre as is
typical in photography studies these
images were about violence against women
what Marianne Hirsch studies among other
things is the idea of post-memory they
were about that they had also to do with
a shadow Archive of 19th century
domestic portraiture they have to do
with what Karen Shima Karen Q McCollum
might call National objection
the sauciness of the images and here
I'll show you this
image of Donna ferrado is a photographer
who is embedded with a husband and wife
named Garth and Lisa on 1980 in the
early 1980s she was working for an issue
of Japanese Playboy on counter-cultural
marriages and so she was embedded living
with them with her young child at the
time and she's following them around and
one night she Witnesses this fight and
she very famously documents this this
violence
ferrado's piece was cut for being
obscene and she caught a lot of flack
for taking the picture rather than
intervening right
I'll show you with this other photograph
I'm going to show it quickly it's of the
artist Anna mendieta who while she was
getting her MFA at University of Iowa
she was by the way known for working
with animal blood
a lot of the male artists were doing the
same a murder happened while she was in
school and what she was moved to engage
in a series of performances which she
called Tableau of violence where she
read the police material about the
describe this murder of this young woman
on campus and she sort of replicated
what the police found
and she
invited some friends over to her home
one evening posed in the way that this
young woman's body had been found she
didn't say anything to the guests it was
a project that involved duration and she
is sloped over a table here's the image
really quickly
um
and eventually the folks that she
invited to her home started taking
photographs and talked about what they
saw
um
Anna mendietta was herself a victim of
domestic violence and her husband the
minimalist sculptor Carl Andre was
accused of pushing her out of a
high-rise building many years later
um and like as I said this was a project
that was part of her early juvenile you
might you might call it and I got
interested in this period of feminist
art performance
um if it's at a moment in the 1980s
where there were caused by critical
white feminist artists who were saying
what we need to do is stop following the
tradition the male tradition of
representing our bodies and take our
bodies out of circulation stop appearing
nude in our art stop making our art be
about our naked form
and what made me interested in these
images given what I had shown you about
the faked domestic violence public
awareness campaigns was the fact that
these women were not doing that these
artists and photojournalists were
straying from that and what I found
really compelling was that though these
are forms of art performance they were
actually mimicking a new form of police
photography of domestic violence of
battered women and I would be remiss if
I didn't tell you that it's precisely
this these kinds of images that got the
police to take domestic violence
seriously right previously for decades
the police would ask
Carl the husband to take a walk around
the block right and nothing really was
done about about what was happening
domestically
um here is another of the famous
photographer Nan golden this is a an
authentic image the image she calls the
image Nan one month after being beaten
and she it's an image of her with a
black eye that she received from an
ex-boyfriend and she's also
um put Rouge put makeup on her face
sorry
okay this is an image that she would
show regularly
um
in an art performance piece that she did
in the 1980s very famous photograph of
her
um and what was compelling about this
image is the makeup and the bruise
together
um in all of these cosmetically
simulated images what I find compelling
is the fact that
makeup is being used in a radical makeup
is being radicalized right makeup is
being used in this activist way
makeup being sort of one of the one of
the Essences of feminine masquerade like
one of the ways that you highlight
femininity one of the ways that you
highlight Womanhood and so I was quite
interested in the ways that makeup could
be used by these female these women
activists in this way in this particular
image that I just showed you kind of has
those two things going on at the same
time
okay
um so how did we get to this place of
advertising law by circulating faked
images of the very real evidence needed
during domestic violence trials
rather than exclusively following the
configuration of women's bodies in these
images right where have I seen this
configuration of bodies before right
rather than ask that question the motifs
of genre that I've that have organized
film and these are the motifs and genres
that have organized film and photography
studies I was led instead by the
dominant terms we used to refer to these
images images of battered women pictures
of intimate partner violence domestic
violence images of DV the images are
used to advertise the medical legal term
is it sorry these images are used to
advertise the medical legal terms for a
particular kind of victim of a
particular violent crime
these images were also used to bring
awareness to policy changes brought
about by the bipartisan efforts of the
violence against women Act of 1994 which
I'll talk more about shortly
what I wanted to do however was not
merely tell the story of these images in
terms of their um the more prominent
content but rather to see what forms of
law were represented through the image
um and so I was really thinking about
domestic violence that term and if you
are in any way connected to the court
system or the social service world you
know that DV is a shorthand a shorthand
that's commonly used to describe these
kinds of crimes
so I realized that I had seen DV
elsewhere and it's in the United States
Constitution in article 4 section for
the guarantee clause which says the
United States shall guarantee to every
state of the union a republican form of
government and shall protect each one of
them against Invasion on the application
of the legislature or the executive when
the legislature cannot be convened
against domestic violence I was quite
interested in how this little D big V
can become and this is the argument of
the book that little D big V can become
Big D big V
and what I mean by Big D big V is the
way that those two letters appear in
court documents to signify a domestic
violence case it's a way of I quickly
identifying through the docket number
might be 2004 DV and then a series of
other numbers that's a quick way for you
to identify through court documents this
is a domestic violence trial and that
that sign
opens up those particular cases for
particular forms of analysis and
monitoring that are quite different than
other criminal cases or other other
forms of charges
so this book is really about this
transformation which I argue is a
transformation that has to do with the
archive of slavery it has to do with the
evidence the archival history of New
World slavery even when
that evidence appears to not be present
right so even when the voices or lives
of slaves appear to be absent from our
from the archive that absence is
actually a presence and so I wanted to
bring the archive of Slavery to Bear
upon this change
change that begins to code legal files
are you with me does that make some
sense okay
um
so
the interesting thing about this moment
and the Constitution this guarantee
Clause is that the United States is
becoming a republic it cannot be a
monarchy it cannot be a dictatorship
though maybe it can be but it has to be
a republic and
in the moment of the Constitution when
this is being debated this Clause by the
Southern and northern states the
southern states interpret domestic
violence the Little D big V they
interpret that as the utter cultural and
economic catastrophe that will ensue
should slaves become free
so domestic violence is not what you
think it is right it is actually
about a debate
of black folks gaining freedom and so
the image of domestic violence and I I
use some abolitionist photography the
image of domestic violence early on
might be
lithographs or Engravings of the Civil
Union Army attacking Southern
plantations that's domestic violence so
how do we get from an image like that to
this image that I just that I began to
talk with that's just really what the
book is about
and what I try to do
um is to take attention away from the
intimate romantic couple
and the Visual Evidence used to
adjudicate it and throw attention more
onto the neighbor
the intimacies of
um the police interacting with with um
with citizens
how much time do I have 15. okay I'm
gonna fast forward a lot
um
uh
in Black studies particularly black
feminist theorists this Memoir slave
Memoir is extremely important it is the
incidence of a life of a Slave Girl by
Harriet Jacobs
who very famously hid in a Garrett for
seven years
on her captor's property and had a
peephole in the Garrett that she was
hiding in and through that Garrett could
see her children playing and her
children didn't know that she was hidden
away in this space for this amount of
time and in the book I make a connection
between that Garrett space with the
peephole and the camera obscura which is
a really important and foundational
pedagogical tool for those folks who
study visual culture and photography and
film
um and I won't explain how the camera
obscure works but it's a very similar
form
um that I could that you can imagine
um in the photography uh what that you
can imagine in the the slave Memoir but
also that gets made here by a white
artist named Ellen Driscoll who renders
um Harriet Jacobs
um loophole of retreat as she called it
I also think about this social media uh
crazy dilemma about the dress and the
different ways you could see the color
the signification of the color blue and
how the Salvation Army would hack that
campaign and say why is it so hard to
see black and blue right what you should
be gathering here and much of the
evidence that I've shown you are that
these are images of white women's bodies
the white woman's body and this is
really old art history and visual
culture argument there's nothing really
new there
um but would what I what it allows me to
say is that if we go back to this
guarantee clause and we know that
domestic violence had been something
else having to do with black Freedom
that it makes us ask about this that
what's being that something is being
ghosted here
and it's the freedom struggles of Black
Folk
okay I won't go through this one but
um as another pedagogical tool I look at
the power and control wheel this is the
sort of cybernetic aspect of things this
feedback loop that is used as a
pedagogical tool in court cases
um
and the reason I call this a cybernetic
thing is that
um cybernetics is a is a is a language
it's a way of describing the division of
labor of machines how do you program a
robot to be able to do labor and this
kind of circular wheel cycle function is
a similar way of describing a feedback
loop of the the exchange of the power
dynamic between the couple and these are
tools that attorneys and experts will
use in Court Domestic Violence Court
cases to help explain to the jury
why women stay in these cases and why
they sometimes for very good complicated
reasons sabotage their own cases why
they the overwhelming majority of women
do not want to participate in this
okay so quickly this leads me to another
project which I'm calling critical
marginalia
um this is yeah this text appears
somewhat small but
as I said at the beginning
um you cannot bring any recording
materials into a courtroom
you have to be load Tech it is an
extremely low-tech environment and the
first and Sixth Amendment of the
Constitution are both a right they they
are interlocking amendments meaning that
we have the right to assemble and we
have the right to a trial of one's peers
we have the right to be seen being
accused and those two
um those two amendments interlock
interlock again I'm using the work of
Jocelyn Simonson
um so we have the right Duty and
obligation as audience members not
juries but audience members to be in a
court so I bring my students in this
class I've created this court watch
clinic and we go and we have I give them
a notebook
um I insist that the notebook be
anonymized and they go and deal with the
overwhelming boredom utter boredom and
confusion of the courtroom they have no
idea what's going on these are folks my
campus is really International they've
they've revealed to me that they've
never been to a courthouse in their own
country they've never been to one in
this country it's incredible for them
that it gets them moving
um and it gets them telling a different
set of stories
and I was very intrigued a by Alyssa
Richardson's book which I adore but also
her talk yesterday and she really
um
digs into the photographs into what the
photographs and what holding a camera in
a student holding a camera can the power
of that and I actually want to make a
somewhat different argument there's
something about the courtroom space
where the phone is not a tool is not
available to young people that forces
you to go low-tech and Lo-Fi and it
forces you to draw and it forces you to
write and what I find interesting is
when I have students they engage in
drawing activities such as this
they engage they have to write in
language that accounts for themselves in
the courthouse they have to deal with
this the griminess the smelliness of the
American court system the courts are
often in disrepair there's a reason for
that
um I have a student who
um
you know they get up they get tied into
how out of date and old and grimy Things
Are
rather than taking a photograph and
saying we got the picture we're woke we
understand we have the critique
what my study is suggesting because it's
located in the courtroom milieu is these
folks do not are not ideologically the
same they do not carry the same ideas
about what it means to document evidence
precisely because they are meant to deal
with the utter boredom and confusion of
legal language it slows everything down
in a way that your ability to use a
smartphone does not do
and so I I highly recommend this as a
pedagogical and storytelling um
potential
another this is a woman who's from Korea
who
was got really tied into the clothing
that they wear these are also folks that
you can see have a manga practice who
very quickly are able to engage in
storyboarding and that's how that's how
cognitively they're able to process the
confusion and boredom of the courtroom
I like this circle that she's making
this feedback loop that she comes to
make
um
people question the architecture of the
Court they end up questioning what women
are wearing what what defendants are
wearing right you really have to ask
yourselves I mean I where I ask myself
what is it that I have here in these
Reflections and these images that
they're drawing I don't think I have
anything
but I think that there is something here
precisely when you put it into context
when you read it against the smartphone
and what it can do and the speed with
which people can very quickly capture an
image
um and with the the kind of ideological
Unity or commonality that we assume is
in place in the moment of of bearing
Witness
um here's another
um that really sort of documents very
nicely the slow creep of the smartphone
in the courtroom when Court Watchers
when sorry when Court officers bodies
are at rest they get bored and they bust
out the phone and they're not allowed to
but they do it anyway so the phone is
slowly making its way into into the
court system and that fine I find that
fascinating
um
let's see
these are moments also where rather than
meeting the police in the streets you're
meeting them on their Turf you're
meeting them or we're meeting my
students they are meeting them in their
home and it makes them very nervous and
they start being
excessively nice but sometimes they let
something slip they say things under
their breath and these are really
interesting moments for us to capture
without the use of without the use of
the phone this is a student I'm
compelled by this image because of the
way that she shows the Shackled hands
and the back
um I might you know I would put this
into conversation with the history of
reading the back
um in in images the archive of slavery
but also images of criminality the
sagging back what that means effectively
one of the things that I try to do in
the book is take the attention away from
um all of the affect of reading the face
but located in Reading other aspects of
the body flesh
the way that your head hangs Etc
so conclusions here I'm just restating
the um the provocation about this closed
circuit relationship between evidence
and the state the state controls it all
they control the authentic images but
they also control the fake ones and we
need to be cognizant of that
I want to also suggest that they're that
the courtroom audience their lives and
the way that they move through the
audience is an absent labor history we
need to understand it that way and that
um what they produce in terms of the
drawings
um
and and and and and Reflections reflect
a diverse set of ideologies they do not
agree they are not all left wing they
are have they have some very
conservative ideas
and they
those ideas are present in the moment of
the court system rather than what we
might assume or prefer they believe
and following Turin Monahan the
interaction between law and counter
archival or surveillance practices which
are these forms of critical marginalia
that I'm talking about
they may serve to blunt their radical
potential because as he says as people
are entrained to participate in systems
of data production they become
compliance surveillance subjects whose
labor generates value for others often
benounced unbeknownst to them end quote
such that quote the very mechanisms that
allow for and encourage participations
by users and data creation also afford
opportunities for artistic and
interventions that illustrate the
Insidious logic of supposedly rational
systems
I could answer questions about any of
those things
um or I'll be happy to clear up any
other things okay thank you
[Applause]
so much
yeah so we have about 15 to 20 minutes
to do q a I'm actually going to
be able to start off with the question
I'm curious Kelly how did
violence against the state legally
become violence against the Flesh and
then eventually violence against
feminine white flesh
uh
in the book
[Music]
um
I talk about I try to orient the
question fundamentally to the violence
of New World slavery and what that means
in terms of restricting the freedom of
black bodies I use the work of Hortense
Spillers to try and answer that question
where she makes this very famous
distinction between the flesh and body
and lots of Scholars have have dug into
that moment in her text where she makes
that distinction the flesh is something
as I read her that can be used to
um
you can control the body but there's
something also there's something
different or extra about the ability to
control the Flesh and I think that
that that meaning in her in her text
changes and I try to show that through
the way that the look the ideal look of
the domestic violence evidence begins to
appear as a white woman whose body is
used as a blank canvas
to show us what domestic violence should
look like and when you put that in
conversation with the cosmetically
simulated images
what you get is the sort of nice way to
train people on how to see these photos
in court right the my fundamental
argument or what one of my arguments is
that the court controls them both and it
opens up by by my saying that it opens
up questions around what kind of
um art practices do certain groups
engage in if you were to look at an art
history of black women art performances
you don't begin to see bare breasts of
of black women artists artists until
late in the game
that's not the case with the way that
white women
um are engaging in radical art practices
the way that they use their bodies and
you could and I wouldn't I mean this is
a very american-centric project I
realized but I really would like to see
myself in conversation with
um the way that other folks are
theorizing our our practices I hope that
makes sense it does thank you sure all
right so I'm going to start at the right
right side of the room with questions
and then we'll move over to the left
University and culture and media and my
work is actually on the trial as a
narrative form so this talk and your
book have been really really
inspirational for me and I was wondering
because you mentioned at the beginning
of uh your talk that public like we're
at the highest point of public
witnessing in the United States while
the actual courtroom trial is decreasing
yeah and I think uh first I think it's
interesting that some of like the most
high profile like media mediated trials
have been civil trials recently with the
Amber Heard Johnny Depp case and then
I've personally been watching the live
stream of Alex Jones's defamation trials
um and I was wondering how this kind of
decree how do you think this decrease in
like the actual like actual cases going
to trials squares with maybe the
popularity of True Crime media but also
kind of in like sleuthing and the act of
kind of investigating especially on
social media in general it feels very
interesting that in reality like there's
not that many cases but it seems like
yeah yeah
um I think the
the camera obscure I think can help us
think about your question which is I
think a very good one thank you
um this was a scientific object the
camera obscure it reveals natural
phenomena and it's used for scientific
purposes but as you see oh you don't see
it
uh hey thank you as you see in these
other chord quadrants this is used by
the bourgeoisie as a as an as a Leisure
as a form of entertainment right so
particularly you know in the west there
is a long cultural tradition of
inhabiting
um machines and even the lives of others
for entertainment purposes and I think
that's part or a lot of what's going on
and people's appreciation of True Crime
um lifetime television for women there
are even I was at a legal studies
conference this summer and heard a
wonderful talk about
um
conferences that happen in in Las Vegas
that are about uh
women staging themselves in you know
these horrific you know violence against
women acts
um as a form of of leisure activity
right as something that's interesting to
watch that's that's fun in the same ways
that we like or similar ways that we
enjoy horror other sorts of genres that
seem distasteful they are very very
pleasurable
and I'm quite interested in and
describing what kind of aesthetic
category do we need to describe that
feeling or that the participation in
those kinds of activities
um yeah I hope that answers it a little
bit
hello excuse me
excuse me uh Charis lupri associate
professor at new house how are you hi
um I I have two kind of very Divergent
points but um one of which I can't and
going through your talk I can't help
thinking about Todd Atkin Aiken and his
comment I think he passed away a few
years ago about legitimate rape right
and legitimate rape women have a whole
women's bodies have a whole way of
shutting that thing down
um and you know this idea of what is
legitimate violence and what is
illegitimate violence and when we talk
about violence against say black and
brown bodies and we've had those
conversations
um that it's
technically legitimized right because
it's part of the rules of state and so
on and so forth but at the same time the
emphasis on Visual Evidence keeps us
from understanding say emotional
violence so I think I don't really have
a question but I feel like there's this
real intersecting positionality of what
we can bear witness to what we can see
versus what we can't see and what we
choose not to see yeah
um with respect to the racialized
understanding of what is legitimate
violence against which bodies yeah thank
you
um
I your talk makes me think again about
these instruments these power and
control wheels and all the things that
are not represented the archive of
slavery is not in this in these
instruments
um and the assumptions that we bring to
these instruments are that the and and
this is borne out in in the in the cases
is that we are always thinking that
these are cases of female victims and
male perpetrators and that is what you
see overwhelmingly it's what I saw
overwhelmingly in the ethnographic work
I did watching these trials but the
dynamic here describes the trans couple
it describes the queer couple it
describes all couples it describes
female perpetrators as well and so I
think your your comment really makes me
think about that and and really try to I
would like to think that the book can
open that question up too that that
we're in this moment where we're you
know finally celebrating queer lives and
people loving who they like but there is
a
there's a whole bunch of work that's
going to need to come out about violence
and control in those relationships as
well and how that goes down just as it
does for straight folks
and very briefly the other note that I
wanted was um and that work is already
ongoing sorry is uh and not to make it
about myself today is my fifth year
anniversary uh and so I'm here and my
husband is not
um but we got married in the courthouse
right and so you know thinking through
that experience of there was only two
couples getting married that day and all
of our families were there to literally
bear witness to this courtroom process
but there were also people who were
there for courtroom processes and I
think the woman that I remember most
clearly was the woman who was bearing
witness to our wedding unintentionally
because she had something else coming up
after we did this whole marriage thing
for these happy couples and I I really
am excited about the idea of what it
means to Bear witness in a courtroom
when there is no videography or that you
can participate in that videography
taken out of the hands of the people and
I don't know it now I'm just I really
wonder who that woman was and I kind of
want to go back and find out who beared
witness to our wedding our marriage
marriage for very very different reasons
very very different reasons and there
were two very different contracts being
put into play your marriage contract and
her perhaps way of using Visual Evidence
to contract her way into the violence
against women act which is the this act
that
takes the pressure off of the victim to
charge uh the batterer right it's not
women it's not the victim who brings
those cases it's the state right that
discretion is is that agency is taken
off of the victim's hands for all sorts
of reasons I'm quite interested in how
the law ends up having to do that given
the the nature of the kind of power and
control Dynamic that's being described
here which I which has just haunted me
for
for the longest time thank you for that
yeah
my name is Jake saslow and I was really
fascinated by your discussion of boredom
and I think attention and coming from a
music background there's a lot of
ambient music studies about how in a
space where there is little that's
actually going on the attention tends to
um really hone in on very different
topics than you would in a much busier
context which I think you discussed
greatly with your students observations
so I was wondering
for you personally though what do you
tend to notice in those places of
boredom what really begins to draw your
eyes in those courtrooms
um
I'm really a theory person so I I'm
really interested in what the boredom
might suggest and the ways that boredom
has to be overcome
and I use a theorist
theorist by the name of Sian Nye to talk
about that she's I think one of the most
offered some of the most intelligent
thinking about aesthetic categories
um and she has this idea of um she sort
of looks at the history of affect and
emotion and how we study it in in
Liberal cultures and the emphasis when
we're in studies of emotions the human
affect system let's say and feelings
um the emphasis is always on what she
calls the grand affects shame
um Joy uh anger really big topics really
big Grand affix but her she wants to
place Ephesus on something that she
calls the minor affects confusion
concern disorientation boredom
those things don't seem very serious but
she makes this really interesting
political argument that it's precisely
those minor Alpha affects of which
awkwardness is included that we really
need to turn to to address problems in a
liberal democracy it's precisely the
when awkwardness has the power to stall
a conversation that confusion actually
produces all sorts of legitimate
misunderstandings amongst groups and
people and individuals that that where
crosstalk ends up happening and so you
don't end up really connecting with a
person and really listening or really
understanding and boredom in the
courtroom is one of those spaces where
you really the students and I we really
have to deal with our bodies and our
feelings in that moment to come to
understanding
I think it'll I think I think you know
using you know nice Theory it I guess it
helps me understand the conditions of of
having your Consciousness unfold uh you
know in a way that I think is different
when you're taking a picture
um and and it makes you more attuned to
why you don't understand something why
you don't understand the draw the genre
how you have how it is that you have to
deal with drawing a picture and
accounting for yourself while also
listening to other people account for
themselves communication is very
difficult I mean it's a miracle that it
happens it's a miracle and it works
um so it I hope that somewhere in there
that's a there's a response to it thank
you
any other questions
I'm trying to see you because the the
light sorry this is more of a statement
rather than a question
um what if the person we have what is
that question well what if the person is
not viable to listening and like the
only way of listening is seeing pictures
to like tell their story or to get other
people to hear their story rather than
them listening because you're talking
about in the courthouse where they're
not listening
um there's a thing called double
Consciousness and people know that
you're not listening people know the
stereotypes that people have for you so
like what would you have to say about
that
um
different forms of communication get
enacted in that moment right when you're
not heard all sorts of you know
calamities can ensue you know through
physical
uh violence that can happen other people
engage they run through a Litany of ways
of communicating when listening breaks
down
um
in the in the courtroom cases in the in
the around the issue of domestic
violence
one thing that happens that I could tell
you about is there are some
photographers who work with battered
women I talk about this in the book
there are photographers who work with
battered women
um
who engage in a kind of therapeutic
practice with them by
having giving them a makeover and then
photographing them and showing them the
beautiful pictures that resulted and a
lot of those women those victims of DV
they are really engaged by that kind of
therapy and it really they cry they're
very moved they're very happy to see
themselves as they should be seen rather
than the ways that they have regarded
themselves in mirrors for example with
bruises on their bodies Etc so this is a
way that has nothing to do with anything
being said it's a kind of therapeutic
practice that's led by photographers to
just put makeup on in the same way that
survivors of cancer your friend you know
friends might shave their heads you know
during chemotherapy or refuse to wear a
wig or wear a wig or do some sort of
other
um
makeover kind of cosmetic activity right
this doesn't have anything to do with
being
um
heard in terms of spoken language right
it's other ways of
of engaging with people communicatively
that seems to be very helpful
I hope that can answer your question a
little bit
we have time for one or two questions
so I have a question I struck by your
research and some of the parallels with
some work that I'm doing right now as
well regarding the way the visual press
can and cannot cover executions in the
United States and how cameras are kept
outside of the building while the state
is able to kill another human being and
my question to you is is whether we're
talking about domestic violence cases
within the court or something like an
execution what what ought we what would
we like the public to be able to see
because clearly there are certain things
that we we don't want them to see but
normatively what would we like them to
be able to understand visually about
what is happening before us regarding
the state and violence and the state's
power here
yeah that's a really beautiful question
um and I
I don't quite have an answer oh
except to say that
for example my book was not written to
try and get some policy changes about
how to improve images for when women are
or victim other victims are dark-skinned
it's a problem it's a problem of the
technology and how your skin behaves on
camera and the light and all of that but
I didn't write this book to try and get
the images to improved that's not quite
the question that I was interested in
and I don't know that that would work
especially given the ways that we I mean
the Rodney King trial has come up many
times in in the sessions here and all of
the you know the evidence and a number
of other cases that we've been through
in the last you know 20 30 years Etc
it's not about improving the image or
the angle at which you are shooting the
material or shooting shooting the events
um
and I think perhaps in the case of
State executions
I'd almost wish the public would have to
on the one hand I would wish that the
public would have to see it all and hear
it all the loss that the relatives are
going to experience on both sides right
and then
on the other hand
um shoot I was losing my train of
thought
oh and then on the other hand if you
look at the history of people going to
courthouses
this was a bunch of racist sexist
fraternalistic people who went to
courthouses very dutifully and was
really happy to watch executions very
happy to watch you know horrible
decisions that ended up getting people
lynched thrown in jail Etc so even the
history it's I don't want to suggest
that
um that Court watching is you know uh
any kind of cure-all
right or the disclosing information in
that way is any kind of curl because the
history of the watching is not a nice
one so I I think your question really
opens up an impasse and I appreciate it
I don't know the answer to that actually
but thank you yeah that's a good
question
can I add one other piece of evidence to
that thought process is where
uh the flag-draped coffins post Iraq war
that we were not allowed to see or there
was you know legal efforts to prevent
the publication of those images
through because of state-sponsored
violence legitimate violence right so I
just wanted to put that one out there to
add into the formula of your cognitive
processes yeah no it's good there was a
really beautiful talk I went to
yesterday by
an indigenous of Maori scholar named
Latoya I don't have the last name she
offered a beautiful
Memorial in many ways of a relative who
was killed uh using a spit Hood
and her family
kind of replicated that killing through
the use of the spirit Hood but they used
they represented it artistically and
similarly to the faked the cosmetically
simulated images that I talk about what
happened
um it is a way of memorializing her her
family that was killed was they they
called upon the very forms of the state
they got allies to dress up in uniforms
that looked like prison guards they got
a car that looked like you know a police
car prison vehicle and they fed it back
to the system so to speak and I think
that kind of work that kind of project
um Cherise you're helping me maybe
triangulate between this question that I
just got before you
about finding ways for this state to see
what it has been done to us
but then again we have this art practice
of really enjoying inhabiting the lives
and pain of others
um in uh in our leisure activities right
we enjoy watching that stuff and
participating in that stuff so this
actually helps bring us back to this
cybernetics question and the loop this
feedback that we just don't seem to be
able to
to break out of and and
I think perhaps I think that I feel like
that's where I where I've ended the
project in a way and I'm really
beginning to think about that feedback
loop and how to live and work outside of
it
yeah so to theorize that space in a
different way
I have a final question related to that
feedback loop because throughout your
talk I was wondering and understanding
that your project is very much
scrutinizing our scrutinization of
visual imagery why is the courtroom the
best space to analyze these visual
images or this evidence knowing that it
does strip a lot of the context away
from the victims as opposed to say some
kind of entertainment the one that comes
to mind might be the color purple that
traces the connections between slavery
and domestic violence quite clearly yes
I don't claim that the court is the best
space it's the space that I was brought
to in this first project one of the
things that the project opened up for me
through thinking about the court space
and thinking about art and law and
authentic things and fake things is this
concept of theatricality
which is not the same as performativity
and I there's something about the forms
of the theater the law of the theater
how the theater works such that we know
we're in a theater such that we know
when something is official versus not
official and I and it's a difficult
concept to Define in performance studies
there's some discussion about it so I'm
thinking about that at the moment so
it's I don't claim that the court is the
best space
um because and if I did claim that I
wouldn't be able to really engage people
who genuinely like true crime or
watching theater and that you know there
really is good television and good
theater out there that produces change I
mean it that does happen I if I were to
say that the court is the best face I I
couldn't speak to those folks very well
right right so that's kind of The Next
Step which is awesome yeah we're out of
time thank you so much thank you
[Applause]